what is the key interest or lending rate
it influences how cheap loans are how
much money is in circulation and whether
the economy grows or shrinks the
benchmark lending rate is the most
important interest rate for the money
markets it's set by the central banks in
Europe
that's the ECB in the u.s. it's the Fed
if the benchmark lending rate is low
banks can borrow money cheaply from the
central bank and then lend it to
businesses and private individuals and
more and more people are taking out
loans to buy a car build a house invest
in the stock market or purchase other
consumer goods that leads to a growth in
industry and creates jobs but when
there's lots of money in circulation the
risk of inflation grows to keep
inflation in check the central bank
needs to raise its benchmark lending
rate but that makes loans more expensive
and slows down the economy heavily
indebted countries can find themselves
struggling to carry their huge interest
burden but in principle at least an
independent central bank shouldn't
really be swayed by such concerns its
job is to keep prices stable
that's why it must either lower or raise
its benchmark lending rate to regulate
the financial markets